[Music]
are you Justin Burning Man
did you go to Burning Man no I didn't go
but my girlfriend's go every year but I
went like two years ago with him yeah
it's crazy it's fun but I haven't been
to Burning Man that's the one Andy have
you been to Burning Man no what's wrong
then dirty hippies out in the desert
they dude sometimes you'll be there and
you'll see like people walk around naked
and what people will be naked
well they will do it and so when we were
there and you're in Center camp which is
where you can buy coffee because there's
you really there's no money exchanged
accepted by your courier I was giving
into the man you have money that's
that's playing the game there was a guy
there and he was buck naked excited you
jump up naked buck naked okay
and so heap except he had a shirt on so
he was like first and he has he's naked
of him the waist down
that's called porky pig in it
[Applause]
Oh
[Applause]
well we do my shirt sounds like you put
a shirt on it no person just has a shirt
on and they're just naked always down
that's like rogue
that's all protects your shoulders from
the Sun what about him yeah just if
you're gonna go no pants just rockin it
doesn't usually that's called shirt I
call it but I like pork you Porky Pig is
better
porky pigs gonna take the nation ya know
I hope not look for that
that's that show people look tuning for
no one wants to see that
you